I finally broke down and bought myself
a plasma TV
check it out I actually hung this on the
wall myself it's good I want to show you
something a lot of people in the room
you need more space
voila right into the wall wow sometimes
I will just stand here and watch
television for hours I love it
I love this TV
hey Captain what's up uh which room is
Sergeant Jeffords oh Terry's in here
with me and Amy we're just having a
low-key night watching House Hunters
International this orthodontist wants to
live in Panama with his strangely old
wife and won't say why can I talk to him
let me check
shh
yeah no he's asleep can I help you with
something I'm concerned that my
presentation isn't Jazzy enough to
compete with Jeffries he's such a
showman I'm thinking about augmenting
the graphs with um
color sir I know I'm debasing myself
anyway give this to Jeffords he's the
artist I'd like him to choose the um
color yes all right no time to turn in
nighty night
okay he's gone now he's got to wait for
K13 to give us the all clear yeah I
wouldn't hold your breath dumb robot
probably rolling through the stairwell
so I should be best friends of this team
k-13 says we are G2G Amy this dish is
lifted party time
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
there's also a double v app here a
triple VIP area and the Centurion Club
Elite viperi sponsored by Sobe lifewater
no one's a lot in there not even us we
also hired 10 huge scary bouncers with
earpieces what up Keith he actually
wants toss me out of a club three years
ago water under the bridge DJ Blunt is
mixing up some new beats Ballers and
ballarats fasten your seatbelts the
perfect Party begins clink now
oh thank God
no one shows up to a good party on time
if anyone had actually showed up right
now the whole party would have been
wrong disaster I don't want to laugh
Hardy
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
I guess that makes me the devil
you are she is she is the devil I'm in
hell
I'm burning help me you shouldn't jump
about that all right we're here for
Daryl and his band
you know what let's also give a shout
out to Phyllis for this awesome party
huh probably the best one that we have
ever had
[Applause]
but the real reason that we are here is
to say goodbye to a guy who we will
probably never ever see again now a lot
of you know that I am an accomplished
songwriter song parody writer I have
done things like beers in heaven classic
or total eclipse of the fart
um I love to sing them but I am not
going to be doing that today I am going
to be doing something I wrote
specifically for Toby
do you know um
Goodbye Stranger Supertramp yeah
it was early morning yesterday
I was up before the dawn
and I really have enjoyed my stay
Toby must be moving on
I'm gonna miss Toby he has a nice
calming presence in the office
[Music]
don't tell him I said this but I always
thought it was kind of cute
[Music]
[Music]
I did okay okay you have no idea the
physical toll the three vasectomies have
a person kissing what are you doing here
what am I doing here I'm here to like
touch this beautiful guy's face that's
like what everyone's doing now right may
I thank you that is soft you drunk I
don't know
um have I been drinking oh my God yeah I
have
okay is that a big deal wait a minute is
this your ex-boyfriend oh dude I'm sorry
yeah I am does that put a damper on your
plans I have sex plans with my
girlfriend enough okay you you look
ridiculous and you smell terrible I
looked fine and I smell legit the record
yes Tom did ask me to go home with him
and if it's been a year ago I would have
done it it would have totally rocked
your world because I learned a lot of
cool new stuff from this guy some other
guys too but I'm not gonna do that
because I'm a grown-up totally
understand totally understand that this
guy was trying to have sex with my
girlfriend
Mindy I'm a man of God and I I'm not
acting like it dude all right no I get
drunk people get drunk sometimes
okay
[Music]
I'm a minister you're trying to kill a
minister you're just yelling our jobs
now maybe we are all right
[Applause]
[Applause]
why did you date this dude because I got
a huge penis really
come on
all right
here we go
okay that's nice
hey there bud you okay okay I'm a new
man oh Eleanor thank you so much for the
advice about shoving my feelings down
deep I feel so much better it's like I'm
surfing on this wave of positivity is
that Janet oh yeah have you met my
secretary Jeanette she's a lot like
Janet but she doesn't pretend like she
has all the answers oh uh hi Jeanette oh
no it's still me Jay
you're so funny and so how many
quarterbacks are in a home run man
repressing your feelings is great yes
feeling stressed all the time and now
it's just so easy babe we need to get
some food into you get you something to
eat I don't eat anything she's perfect
hey turn that around
hey babe yeah how about we take the beer
sign down until our guests leave and
then we can discuss it no no
I'm gonna leave it up I'm gonna get Ty's
the whole room together
okay
Jack thinks Hunter's very talented
you know what
I don't think he's that good at least
he's an artist BFG I'm a screenwriter
and I'm a Candle Maker but y'all hear me
bragging about it no all you do is you
get me to try to work on my rich friends
opportunity man I would love to burn
your candles you burn it you buy it
I'll be your first customer you're
hardly my first
[Music]
that is a 200 plasma screen TV you just
killed good luck
paying me back on your zero dollars a
year salary plus benefits babe
foreign